welcome everybody to another ideas that
matter conversation I've got here a
friend and colleague uh Rob Colter who
is at uh University of Wyoming where he
holds a position which is a teaching
position of senior lecturer he's also
the department chair there for you know
as I suppose they'll let you do it as
long as you want because it's
service the dirty little secret of
Academia nobody really wants to be chair
or people who do we shouldn't let them
be there right and we're going to be
talking about uh philosophy as a way of
life which which Rob has uh designed and
taught a class on quite a bit but he
also runs an annual stoic Camp that's
been going on for quite a while and this
is kind of an interesting model for
education and he and I have another
thing in in common teaching in prisons
which I don't I haven't done for a while
myself but Rob is still heavily engaged
in out there in Wyoming so anything else
in your bio that I I should have hit on
that yeah I mean I don't know mean I'm
I'm trained uh in ancient Greek and
Roman philosophy that's yeah that's sort
of my uh philosophical specialty as well
as philosophical pedagogy and and
philosophy as the way of life as you
mentioned so so let's talk about you
know usually when we hear this term
philosophy is a way of life it's not
done so much in academic departments
it's usually more like the popular
philosophy that's out there but you get
to teach a class on it and you've done
that a number of times so you know when
you've got a specific um thematic
emphasis on it rather than just
smuggling it in as the rest of us do
from time to time um how does that work
for I mean I assume your department is
supportive as the chair of course you
can make it do whatever you want but uh
you know before you were a chair you had
to pitch this and what was what were
their views on it well I mean um gosh
yeah I mean I think most of us are
trained most philosophy phds are
trained uh to think about philosophy as
an academic exercise right one in which
we go to conferences and talk to each
other about you know abstruse details
you know well in line 6 e of uh
Aristotle's categories you know or
whatever it is right um I think I
probably mix that up a little bit but I
quite yeah right right I mean that's
kind of the point right um and you know
I you know I've done my share of that
sort of stuff um but I don't know most I
had been doing my camp for a while which
really is an exercise and philosophy as
a way of life yeah um and happy to talk
more about that right so so my
department was already pretty on board
and and we had a relatively new
colleague that we had hired uh who was a
PhD from Notre Dame uh and about that
time uh at Notre Dame uh Megan Sullivan
had gotten a big melon
Grant designed to think about how we
might start introducing philosophy as a
way of life into University and College
curricula um so I was fortunate enough
to be uh forget what the title is like a
fellow of that or whatever it was and um
along with my colleague and uh so we
went and we talked about and we learned
from there was at the time there was
maybe
like a handful of colleges and
universities that were doing something
like this and they'd been doing starting
it up at Notre Dame and there's a a
program at Wesleyan University there was
somebody at a community college in Utah
who was doing some interesting stuff in
this area so we were able to you know
just like have these conversations with
people thinking about it people actually
doing it and um yeah so the
course that we came up with that we
designed it had um you know we we
thought
about how we might do it and and we
decided we'd focus on four traditions
okay um yeah that seems manageable
rather than trying to cover everything
body yeah you can't cover everything
right but you know so we started with
some Socrates okay right who sort of
gives us the fous line about the
unexamined life isn't worth living for a
human being and and um from which a
number of philosophical schools have
taken some
inspiration uh then we did a little bit
of stoicism which you and I have had
multiple conversations about and uh um I
we did um existentialism and
neoism okay right so more recent stuff
so like Tolstoy and sart and debois yeah
yeah and and uh we did historical
Christianity so things like Augustine
and aquinus and contemplation and all of
that sort of stuff and uh and then the
last one was why am I blanking out
um oh Confucianism okay yeah that right
Chinese Confucianism so we were able to
pull from a variety of time periods a
variety of sort of cultural backgrounds
um and uh we looked at also some
contemporary scholarship about
philosophy as a way of life in kind of a
very light-handed way about what it
means
to have a philosophy a way of life to
engage in philosophy as a way of life
and this sort of idea all comes from
this French scholar Pierre Hado you
probably know that um who are
articulated this idea looking at the
ancient Greeks um as well as some other
Traditions right this sort of
distinction between the academic Ivory
Tower kind of how many angels can dance
on the head of a pin sort of philosophy
that we all kind of well not all of us
make fun of but some of
us I mean the people who are engaged in
that often don't make fun of it and they
make fun of it and and and truth be told
probably in my younger days I didn't you
know that's what I was doing yeah um uh
yeah so so we talk about that and we
compare these different traditions and
one of the things I I have them do in
the class on a regular basis for each
tradition is like look at these texts
and can we what is livable in them right
right what is what sort of practices
things one might do do you get out of
this of these various Traditions right
so out of Christianity we get things
like prayer and medit meditation out of
uh Confucianism there's a whole bunch of
stuff about ritual and um out of
stoicism there's all this stuff about um
you know well meditation in maybe a
different way than you might get in the
Christian tradition um and uh you know
even like uh
sensory deprivation and challenging
exercises you can get out of senica and
things like that so let me ask you
something um I I also teach a a
philosophy is a way of life class but
only every like maybe third semester
because I teach it at Milwaukee
Institute of Art and Design and in order
to get it into the course catalog I
couldn't call it philosophy as a way of
life we had to call it to make it a
little bit juicier philosophy
mindfulness in life right and so I find
ways to talk about mindfulness and all
that so what I typically end up doing is
I have them read texts and then I say
okay here's the practices that we're
going to try out but if I understand
what you're saying you're actually
asking the students themselves as they
read the text to figure out what the
practices are you're giving them a bit
more initiative than I right am giving
my students yeah and and I think the
coolest thing that this course
does um and I don't know this would work
in all contexts but um and this
has been built off of um some work that
some other people have done right but
one of the things we read at first is
Plato's apology right the apology of
Socrates right and he talks
about all how he lives his life right
and what convictions Drive Socrates and
so on and about the choices he's made in
those lives and and apology um you know
means apologia in Greek means a defense
speech right it's nowhere does Socrates
say I'm sorry right right what he does
almost saying the opposite of that yeah
right right right so he's giving a
defense of his life right so I actually
asked the students to do that oh of
their lives up to yeah well not
necessarily of their whole life right so
we narrow it down a little bit okay we
start off the very first assignment is
okay let's think about some sort of
choice you've made some sort of decision
some sort of value you have imagine
someone is challenging you on those like
socrates's accusers in the dialogue
yeah and um how would you defend that
choice or value or right and and so you
get all sorts of other things you I've
gotten some really interesting things at
that initial stage you know things like
well my parents really want me to major
in engineering but I love music so yeah
you know I asked them to articulate
using the uh Socrates and the apology is
a bit of a model right here's what my
accusers are saying about my choice or
about myc decision or whatever and
here's what I say response but then I
asked them to do it again at the end of
the course okay when they've got more
sort of philosophical thinking about how
one might
situate um uh values and and uh um
arguments and other sort of
philosophical structures into thinking
about one's life then I asked them to
revisit either revisit the same sort of
choice or or or think about um something
else that's come up in the in the time
and I also ask them to look forward
right um
to
um to what sort of decisions they might
see coming down the road and how might
they apply some of the things that
they've learned thought about and so on
right so so it's not just this is one of
the things I'm most excited about this
course is the course is not just about
philosophy as a way of life it is an
exercise in philosophy as a way of life
you know students you mentioned that one
of the things that you are a specialist
in is is philosophical pedagogy and this
strikes me as the sort of thing where
you know when we when we want to as we
should provide um you know evaluation
assessment data to people to show that
we're actually teaching something I I I
used to be totally anti- assessment and
then I found good means of assessment
and I was like okay there's there's a
point to this yeah you know doing that
uh
Preparatory exercise and then finishing
exercise it strikes me you could look at
the same student and say okay what
growth of am I observing between early
and and late absolutely and you could
actually in some ways quantify that you
know using rubrics and then demonstrate
that real learning is taking place yeah
yeah yeah and you and you know the sorts
of things I look for are things like
clarity about relationship between
values and actions okay yeah yeah um uh
you know how well do they consider
counter you know arguments against their
position right A lot of times in their
first ones they don't take seriously the
objections right they kind of strawman
them or something like that and and one
of the things hopefully they learn how
to do is is to sort of put the strongest
possible opposition up there and and
think about it um yeah it's a it's a
cool course and U I get a lot I mean
it's also somewhat effective in recr
students which is nice Majors you mean
yeah yeah yeah okay yeah which is which
is nice that's that's important I mean
we should for people who don't know much
about how Academia works we should talk
about this a little bit because if you
want to have not just a philosophy
department but any any Humanities any
Arts departments you have to be able to
make a case to the administrators that
they should keep paying you to do what
you're doing and it's not enough to say
oh the life of the mind is inherently
valuable which is true but they don't
care and taxpayers you know they want to
see a return on investment and generally
the way we often measure this is well
how many people are studying your your
topic how how many people are taking
your your classes so a class being an
effective recruitment tool and not a
recruitment tool in a kind of BS way
like oh it's you know sexy topic so they
they stream in and then they they leave
something that has real sticking power
where people will say hey this is
valuable for me I'm I'm considering now
becoming a minor or a major or
participating in a club or something
like that um that seems like it's a way
to make an argument for your continued
existence you know yeah no absolutely I
mean at at a sort of bean counter level
right yeah there's sort of like two big
things we have to do uh to justify our
existence one is uh we have to recruit
majors and minors and then we also have
to support them through graduation right
and uh oh yeah right I mean so
graduation rates are something that at
least at my institution we look at and
um no of course the smaller the faculty
is those two things can start to
compete you know true
yeah but that's yeah it's an interesting
puzzle that's what allows you to make a
case too when somebody retires that
should get replaced or maybe you need a
new new additional line created you know
yep now we've got some retirements
coming up uh in the next couple years so
yeah I mean the national trend is that
most in the humanities not just in
philosophy in in history and in English
and you know all these sorts of things
people retire and then they don't get
replaced or if they do get replaced it's
by adjuncts rather than by full-time
teachers and um you know again I think a
lot of people outside of Academia
including many of the parents that are
sending their kids to places just have
no clue I I know that when I so I'm an
adjunct and I've taught as an adjunct in
a lot of places and most of the students
have no idea what the distinction would
mean between adjunct and a a full-time
person and they have no idea who's
actually teaching their classes they
they'll often Say Hey I want to take a
class with you next semester and I'll
say well you know your because I'm not
I'm not here you know yeah or I will say
uh to be fair so some places are really
good with that Milwaukee Institute of
Art and Design all of us adjuncts have
continuing work um they they you know
were considered part of the faculty but
there's plenty of other places where you
are a Hired Hand and you know I mean
even I won't say this it's not as if
those places the full-time faculty have
it easy either you know right so no it's
tough right I mean one of the things
that's good for the students is is
faculty continuity right yeah uh um and
um you know if there's some sort of
sense of how the curriculum builds right
um You can get I think I think a better
educational
product uh out of having more permanent
faculty and there are there are
legitimate times and reasons I think we
have to rely on temporary faculty um you
know
we're having one of my colleagues is
going to be on sabatical next year right
and yeah and and so we're going to have
to hire
hopefully you know a couple people um to
do a couple classes but and of course
being geographically isolated like we
are in Wyoming it's a little tricky
right so yeah so it looks like at least
at least one of those classes is going
to have to be online which would have
been in person which is
also in my view not as good at least for
philosophy um but yeah it's an
interesting time so coming back to the
class
um it being a recruitment tool means
that the majority of the students taking
it are not philosophy Majors right well
the the way it works in our curriculum
is we we first built it as a first year
seminar so just for
freshman and it was capped at 24 I think
and okay filled the cap no problem um
but yeah so they were they were students
who like were like hey that sounds
interesting you know but uh or or there
were some who are like oh I want to take
that I know something about that right
and more and more there are people like
oh I've heard about this stoicism got
the word of mouth thing yeah yeah yeah
yeah or you know
um yeah so so that's interesting and as
you know right philosophy is not
something that gets taught in high
school very often yeah right so so most
college students who discover philosophy
discovered in college right sometimes
you know even their sophomore junior
years and
um and they might fall in love with in
their junior year but they're already
you know three4 of the way through their
degree and they can add a major
something like that so our point was to
really sort of make this a first year
student
thing um but yeah it's I mean I don't
know whether it's more or less effective
than some other courses but it you know
I I think it's been pretty effective
that way well what would be the other
courses that wind up being particularly
good for getting people to see that
philosophy is something they want to
continue to study like intro and epics
and stuff like that yeah you know we've
got an intro to philosophy course we've
also got
some uh a critical thinking course we're
trying to spread like a
virus I mean yeah so we're actually
going through a revamping of our
University core okay requirements and
we're actually trying to get that loaded
into there there are a few universities
that have a critical thinking you know
fville State University where I taught
for three years that was the only
philosophy course that was a required
course for every student within the
university and we didn't have a program
we we offered only a minor because we
were part of a department of government
in history which I actually liked I I
like these in disciplinary departments
um and I had a colleague who had a
really funny idea you mentioned you know
I forget the word that you used it
wasn't infection but it was something
like that and he would talk about we
need to make philosophy a very
successful parasite yes so what we want
to do is um with the critical thinking
class we want to build off of that and
not only make every student take it but
we want to do like critical thinking
across the curriculum or ethics across
the curriculum you go over there and I
was doing stuff with the the business
people because believe it or not they
did not have a business ethics class at
all in the curriculum and they were
going through a
aasb uh reaccreditation yeah and you
gotta have one yeah they want to see
that like e ethics is actually being
taught and just having a class isn't
enough for them so we were like we're
gonna get our fingers in all the little
pies and we won't be like running
anything but everybody will need us and
they'll never be able to fire us as a
result no that's that's the sort of
thing we're trying to do I mean I think
infection is perfectly valid word in
this context right yeah I mean could you
make a case that it is a symbiosis
rather than a mere parasitism because we
are providing value right yeah I think
so I yeah I really think so I mean you
know we're working right now with our
School of Pharmacy about how we might
that's another good one yeah about how
we might provide their ethics
programming that they need for their
accreditation right their accreditation
and Licensing has to have an Ethics
component I I have a client who is a
pharmacist in a hospital down in
Louisiana and he's you know he's about
our age and I've had a lot of good
conversations with him um over the years
and I would ask him so are you know what
are the sort of issues that you actually
face in in the pharmacy and he'd be like
oh man as a hospital guy I've got it so
much easier than these guys who are like
at Walgreens or CVS or Walmart or stuff
like that and then I asked them so did
any of the classes that you took prepare
you for these conflicts crises issues
that you're going to face and he's like
they didn't give us a single bit of
useful prep for that now he you know
he's older like us so obviously it
wasn't part of the curriculum at the
time but for these professional areas of
life that have a lot of social Prestige
these things are are are so important to
have yeah considerations of Ethics
that's right I mean other things too I
mean with the philosophy as a way of
life
resiliency absolutely yeah absolutely um
you know so
I yeah yeah I mean it's it's interesting
business needs an Ethics component for
its licensers and stuff like that and
other healthc care stuff even
engineering right um oh yeah they're
often a little impatient with it yes
indeed well and in business it often
becomes well pardon my cism
uh really about compliance right that's
true and and actually one of the things
that there's an article the
um the I forget exactly the title but
it's about this this idea of the
business case for business ethics which
is that um you should do business ethics
you should study business ethics you
should be ethical because it it pays off
in the bottom line which doesn't always
turn out to be true um but you know is
this something that we should be putting
forward and we get these purists in in
ethics who are like we must never say
anything like that because we're you
know we're duding ethics if we do that
yeah and clearly that's the wrong way to
do it because we lose like 90% of the
people who might care but we also don't
want to just make it be about compli
that's right right there's Middle Ground
there I mean that reminds me I mean so
you mentioned of course that we both
taught in prisons and I run our
University's prison education program in
Wyoming now and uh last year we had
invited not just not just it was like a
group like philosophy and and other
Humanities programs invited Angela Davis
to campus oh wow and I got to have
dinner with her and had a
conversation and
um I asked her I said you know so one of
the things that bothers
me sometimes right is is um you know I
think there's a lot really broken about
our justice system system right but in
order but in order to be able to be
inside there providing education to
these incarcerated students I have to in
some ways and I have to have all of my
instructors in the program and stuff be
complicit with some aspects that we
don't necessarily like so
much um and maybe think are really
broken or wrong or unjust or something
like that and so I asked Angela Davis
who's you know a you one of the foremost
figures in philosophers thinking about
our our car system um historically I
asked I asked her I said how does how do
you reconcile that stuff you know I mean
yeah and and and she looked at me and
and um she just said um well I'm
paraphrasing this part she said we just
got to get over that and uh keep doing
the good
thing and then a little bit later she
said to me and this is what what you
were just saying about ethical P She
Goes Purity is the
enemy
yeah but I did have the thought I wonder
if the Angela Davis of 1975 would have
said the same thing but but uh the
Angela Davis of 2023 was like you know
too much Purity prevents you from doing
anything yeah that's true and you know
the prison and I hesitate to call it a
system because it's not a system but
just a patchwork of interconnected
systems each Doc is different from from
state to state and all that but if we
want to say like there's an overall
system it's gotten worse since the 70s
when they at least still had some belief
in Rehabilitation and now it's mostly
you know incapacitation or retribution
that's that's driving
warehousing yeah and and you know the
warehousing conditions have in many
respects gotten worse too more
exploitative you know you know you look
at the fact that like prisoners can
email you more easily now I mean email
didn't exist back then but they charged
you know through these that are usually
no bid contracts they they charge these
prisoners and their families exorbitant
rates to to do basic human things you
know you know and and to shift this a
little bit so you mentioned that you
have them uh in your classes and you and
you also said that uh when we were
talking before that you teach this
philosophy as a way of life class um to
regular undergrads but also to prison
students y so with existentialism I you
know people will quibble is kamu an
existentialist I mean I I'm willing to
say yes he's within that penumbra of
course when he talks about
existentialist he means you know shesto
and Marcel and yaspers and people like
that um but kamu really poses that same
problem you know no matter what you do
you're collaborating in some way with
something that you can you can say is
unjust or wrong or damaging to human
dignity and so what are you going to do
throw up your hands and say not going to
do anything that doesn't seem like a a
workable alternative and and he took a
lot of flak from people for not you know
taking a hard position on Algeria and
then saying hey my mom lives there you
know yeah yeah so I I I'm kind of I'm
I've become myself as I've gotten older
I've become much more receptive to that
sort of um light a candle rather than
just curse the darkness sort of yeah
yeah abolutely I maybe this is a bit of
a reflection of our age our our maturity
right that but um you know uh I
think yeah it if we aren't doing
something then we're really just sort of
spinning and um you know and that's but
I think that's also really reflective in
this distinction right that we started
with between philosophy as a way of life
as a way of living in the world as it is
rather than the sort of academic Ivory
Tower quibbling about the you know I
mean we can argue about the sources of
Injustice in the Cal system or in the
economic system or whatever you want but
but then for me anyway there came a
point where well if I'm not doing
something to
help just talking about it doesn't
matter and I don't know about you
and
but I think writing academic articles
doesn't necessarily help very much
either I there exceptions yeah that's
where I was going to go with this I was
going to say people can write articles
about Justice or even philosophy as a
way of life but um that falls short
unless it's tied in with something
tangible something that involves
relationships with people and I'm not
saying that everybody has to be an
activist all the time right you know but
I'm also you know I'm also tempted to
think that a lot of um what seems to be
engagement in social media really
doesn't do much of anything either right
yeah yeah yeah no it's I mean that's
actually kind of one of the things that
inspired me to start thinking about
philo's way of life and it really sort
of started with my Camp okay if if you
want to go you should talk at length
about that because I think a lot of
people you know they're familiar with
the idea of camp and they're familiar to
some degree with stoicism but put the
two of them together and probably have
no IDE they're they're they're probably
thinking like so what do you do you got
to like run across hot coals or they
beat
you oh you're giving me ideas let
me so I I distinctly
remember so there was a time I think it
was about
2012 that I was um you know as as
happens I was having a bit of a midlife
crisis sort of situations some stuff
going on in my life and you know like I
said you know I've
been trained in ancient Greek and Roman
philosophy and I teach courses in this
stuff and I was teaching a
course um and I was teaching epic tetus
is inidian
okay and I was you know reading inidian
one right the famous bit some things are
up to us and some things are not up this
and and I I was just I was reading it
aloud in the classroom for dramatic
pedagogical effect
and I it something just like clicked in
my head I was like oh wait you could
actually do
this right I mean I I had approached it
theoretically I'd been teaching it for
years right and and I sort of like uh
you know my early work was all on like
Plato and Aristotle's epistemology and
metaphysics right so so I'm I'm uh
reading this stuff and I'm like you
could actually do this and my life was I
was having some real problems in life
and and so I was like I wonder if
anybody's like actually doing anything
right so I literally got back to my
office started Googling okay and I found
um
the the like um live like a stoic week
stuff that they were doing over with
Chris Gill and John cers yeah yeah yeah
right like very early on right back when
uh uh when it was first coming together
yeah yeah Patrick Usher when he was
involved and so yeah so I emailed
Chris and I said hey could I like borrow
some of this stuff and I've got an idea
I want to do it and he was like yeah
take whatever you want right so I I was
teaching uh a a seminar on helenistic
philosophy and I said let's just throw
in this live like a stoic week thing and
um so I did with this seminar and it
people responded to it and I was
responding to it and and and I said I
wonder if anybody's ever thought about
doing this in a real immersive
way and I'm like you know living agre in
agree with nature that's stoicism well
one thing we have a lot of in Wyoming is
nature um so then you know I just
started calling around and I found this
um what's primarily like a a kids Bible
Camp place up in the mountains west of
laramy Wyoming and
um I said you know I just figured out
how much my C to have some people and so
I did a pilot little thing mostly
populated by people in that
seminar uh and we went and did like a
three-day weekend
and it went really well and so the next
year I opened it up and and I put a
flyer out at stoicon and um and uh next
thing you know I had people from all
across the country coming and and it
started out I don't know there's 20 25
people that first year people from New
York Minnesota California
um as well as students from not just
University of Wyoming but some of the
regional colleges where I had colleagues
and was telling them about it and stuff
and and it's since since then it's grown
and um you know it's open to anybody
last year we had 38 people and I'm I'm
going to have to cap it at 40 I think
but um we had 38 people a handful came
from Europe oh okay um and we go up in
the mountains for 5 days and we um we go
to this site and people hold up in
cabins you know with bunks and um it's a
little bit rustic not like you know
people aren't living in barrels for
example uh um but uh it's a little bit
rustic without being too primitive um
and we we read stoic texts in large
groups in small groups I've developed a
workbook kind of based off of that
original live like a stoic week stuff
that I give to everybody and people
journal in it and they do some of the
exercises that we've you know over the
years have sort of departed from exactly
what they're doing with stoic week and
stuff a bit but um oh and I think that's
a good thing you know because um
different formats you know an immersive
format I think stoic week still has the
idea of like you do a bit of this each
day you're not doing it all day
right right and it's going to have some
some effects but if you're doing
something where it's deliberate and and
immersive like that I it has to be a
different uh you know set of exercises
and readings and Y yeah yeah so we do
it's really pretty intensive and then we
have bonfires we go on Hikes and try not
to get trampled by Moose or or eaten by
a bear I've not actually seen any bear
although was it last year yeah it was
last year there was a whole family of
moose in the middle of the the campsite
oh wow one night um and uh and I had to
tell the Europeans to watch watch oh
yeah i' I've seen them in Upstate New
York and they are scary when when you're
and they're very territorial right so
but yeah that and then we have guest
lectures come in in the evenings
colleagues from so I've had colleagues
from University of Wyoming colleagues
from uh University of Colorado from
University of Den have come up um
they'll come up and do an evening kind
of fireside chat literally by the fire
and yeah yeah and um and we do it in May
every year um I do it right after our
school year ends um and uh that way some
of the students who might want to come
uh don't go away and it's harder to get
them back right right yeah um but yeah
it's it's it's a and it's great for me
too to like sort of immerse myself in it
at the end of a school year I um I think
it's great and you know maybe when we're
done here if we want to talk about
bringing you out as a guest lecturer I
be happy to and I I want to say
something too so like you know you
finding it useful to do it yourself so
I've said something like this with stoic
week in the past because I think I the
first one I did was maybe
201 13 or
14 and I thought it was great you know
and you know we we completely change
things up year to year sometimes there's
a slightly different theme but much of
the stuff is the same and so you can say
well doesn't that at old and stale and I
look at it as like it's an opportunity
to you know like do a tuneup you know
with the old fashioned the old fashion
cars that we used to be able to work on
that I mean now I can't work on mine at
all so you know you'd have these spark
plugs and they'd get out of alignment
with each other and you have to tune
them and that's what it's tune and so
even though things are really really
seem seemingly basic some of these
things if you're a practitioner if
you're somebody who's been working with
it for a while there's a tendency to to
make the mistake of saying oh I don't
really need to worry about that anymore
and so it's kind of good to be brought
back it's sort of like being a musician
and having to do scales again right um
or drills you know these these arpeggios
and things like that so I I I I think
that's a great idea um to have to redo
the same thing that's right and and you
know what we usually do is we like we do
some interesting things I think um we
read aloud to each other oh yeah I mean
a different mode right of taking in the
material both for the reader and for the
listener yeah and it's you know it's
it's a method straight out of Plato
right yeah I
mean you know I was I I was just
teaching the lisses today oh nice and it
was kind of funny because because you
know lissus is this this kid essentially
you know an adolescent and Socrates is
saying hey your parents let you do
whatever you want he's like they don't
let me do anything you know and so he's
like do they let you um you know work
with when the soup you decide what to
add to it and they're like that's the
cook they they wouldn't let me touch it
you know and so Socrates finally says
well do they let you do anything and
he's like yeah they let me read aloud
yeah yeah yeah that's funny I was just
talking about that part of the of that
dialogue at the APA last week oh really
yeah I was doing a a thing on Socratic
pedagogy at the APA and and I was
looking at passages from the lissus and
from the Lackey okay I would be
interested to see that actually yeah
yeah yeah be happy to share so so coming
back to the the the camp thing um what
what are the participants I mean let me
ask you two questions first of all are
there repeat customers so to speak yeah
and and what do they what do they say
that they get out of it yeah yeah I mean
so definitely repeat customers um I
think the current winner of consec I
think he's been like seven consecutive
times is a colleague of mine in math in
the math department so he he's the one
who wants to press me on like cipus and
okay right and we talk about you know
cipan logic and and uh determinism and
and freedom in that sense right and then
the rest of the room kind of goes to
sleep for a while yeah um uh and um I've
even had like some Europeans be repeat
customers flly over interesting uh yeah
from England or from Germany and um you
know some students graduate and then
keep coming back um I mean for some of
them again it's a tuneup like you were
just talking about right yeah my
colleague in math right
he um you know he keeps coming back and
he loves having the tuneup and and you
know
I I do a combination of trying to change
the texts up a little bit here and there
and sometimes we loop back around yeah
um you know I one year I tried Elizabeth
Carter's translation of epitus okay
which nobody reads right but you know
the first one into English in the 18th
oh yeah and that was fun I had that um
yeah we'll come right back to the
question but I'm going to tell you this
this really short story so I you know my
undergraduate philosophy was pretty piss
poor my professors kind of didn't care
and didn't have any idea what was going
on in contemporary philosophy and they
had other stuff to do they were they're
getting close to retirement and so you
know I read epic tetus Ed cidian and
their their take on it was he this is
STO stuff it's not really important like
Aristotle and Plato are and and I read
it and I was like it's kind of cool but
I don't think I want to practice all of
this sort of stuff and I had no idea
that epic tetus had any other texts and
I'm in graduate school and in in my gr
School of course nobody cared about the
stoics either except in so far as Delo
might have mentioned them about this or
that sort of thing and uh I was in a
used book
store and I'm you know digging around on
the philosophy stuff and there's this
like green
cover volume that has her translation in
it and um I opened it up and I'm like I
don't know epic just wrote more stuff
and I'm reading it and it's one of those
things where you're in the bookstore and
you'll just like stay there for an hour
reading a a book and I'm like holy crap
this is this is incredible stuff because
I was really interested in like the you
know what is the will how do we form our
character those sorts of things that's a
seminal text on that yeah yeah and so
anyway it was that trans
that got me steered into taking epicus
much more seriously so back to your your
uh uh account of the what people are
getting out of yeah yeah so so I mean a
lot of
people you know so people also come in
with widely
ranging
um backgrounds with stoicism right so
people who listen to all the podcasts
and go to stoicon and stuff like that I
mean so one guy came from
England uh and
he he saw me at stoicon in Athens in
2019 okay and overheard me talking about
my camp with
somebody um and he sort of like filed it
away and so you know that sounds kind of
cool kind of crazy and then of course Co
happened and the the whole world went
upside down right and then he emailed me
back he says all right so I've been
hunting you down since
2019 right I think I found you and I
found your website and there's this
picture of delie on a on a rainy day and
that's what it was like and and you were
there and and I was there and and so and
I'm like yep come to Camp if you want so
he did and uh um and then I looked at my
pictures on the phone and there's a
picture at doy with the two of us in the
picture oh interesting super wild yeah
so you get people who've been kind of
invested in in stoicism in some way or
other but then I also get students who
are like well I had I had your I liked
your class and I loved going to the
mountains and let's do that right and so
what they get out of it I think
is
um probably a difference there's
probably different but they all sort of
like start in one place and move to
another one of the things I try to get
across in the camp is that it's an
opportunity um for us to look pretty
deeply and think deeply and kind of
slowly about some of these ideas and and
I ask people to like kind of like try it
on like it's a you know like a coat yeah
yeah and see if it fits and if it
pinches and if you know let's just try
it out I'm not trying to vert
anybody um but let's let's take a look
at this pretty deeply and slowly and try
it on and some people find out that it
fits some people find out that it
doesn't and all those options you know
and and a wide range of stuff in between
I like this stuff I don't like that I
I'm going to use this uh um you know and
um you know it's a wide range of sort of
stuff I have I do get though a lot of
people who have just
um you know been exposed through the
like podcast or social media sort of
level stuff come away tell me they came
up with a Come Away with a much deeper
understanding of all of this well that
makes perfect sense because I
mean I I don't want to turn anybody off
from podcasts or uh you know people love
to throw these quotes out there and
fortunately a lot of them are actually
fake yeah
um but you know son talks about that in
letter 33 because lilus is essentially
asking him for give me some quotes I
mean they call him maxims yeah and he's
like well I'm not gonna do that here and
he gives a bunch of reasons why and some
of the reasons are you know kind of
funny like hey the stoics have so much
good material that to pick anything out
would be arbitrary you know it's all at
the same high level which clearly is not
the case um but you know there's there's
a lot of really great stuff um but then
senica says listen it's a system it's
not something to just cherry-pick a
bunch of stuff from it's it's a coherent
way of thinking things out and then
towards the end he's like all right
buddy I'll I'll give you some just yeah
right well well I mean he always ends a
letter with a quote right yeah but I
mean there is something to that it's
it's uh you're G to get so much more out
of and I think you could say that so
I'll ask you this whether this applies
to every everything that we could call a
philosophy as a way of life there's some
deep rich network of ideas and they work
better when you've got more of them
connected and you actually understand
them and you can you know apply them to
how you live rather than I mean
Confucianism could be reduced down to
the silly caricature of you know
confucious say you know that we had as
kids in like cartoons and stuff but
that's not the same thing as like
reading the analects or reading you know
Neo confucious and their their
commentaries on this kind of stuff right
no I think that's right I mean you know
there have been Scholars recently have
really been trying to sus out what
exactly
makes something a philosophy as a way of
life and and okay yeah I I don't think
it's really been solved yet I I haven't
been satisfied by anybody's solution but
but there do seem to be
some some features
that well let me put it this way
so maybe we could talk about a
philosophy of life or philosophy's way
of life in a way that captures a whole
bunch of stuff right like um you know
from silly like uh what is it uh live
hard and die young right yeah is that a
right something like that right
um but a good successful one seems to
demand something quite a bit more than
that right something systematic right
right such that like you there's a view
of the
world right the way the world the way
the universe works yeah there's a view
of what it is to be
human
and they those two things got to work
together yeah right or or you get a
train wreck I would say you could even
have things that satisfy that but wind
up being ultimately bad for people and
so you know the the example that's my
go-to for that I Rand articulates a
philosophy as a way of life it just
happens to be one that if you do adopt
you're probably going to screw yourself
in your relationships and other things
up in the process and actually you know
if if that gets you out of being I don't
know living a totally hedonistic
day-by-day lifestyle that could be like
a decent Gateway into something more
serious let's say you read Rand and and
she's a terrible reader of uh other
thinkers but she really loves Aristotle
right her Aristotle is not real
Aristotle but let's say you read her and
you're like well I better read this
Aristotle guy because he really likes
him and then you start reading say
Aristotle's necam McCain ethics and
you're like oh I guess I'm not an egoist
anymore yeah right that category doesn't
really apply here I'm gonna I'm gonna
adopt this as a philosophy as a way yeah
yeah yeah no I think that's right but I
I think that sort of systematicity is
perhaps necessary but not sufficient
okay good good distinction
one that we use in academic philosophy
all the time yeah sure right so I mean
but you know the sufficiency question
right is is I think much harder
um you know and it I'm not sure some
might want to say well it's truth right
if it's if it's systematic in the right
way and it's
true I'm not convinced that that's the
right one um and um well there's a lot
of different ways to look at truth
and right I mean do we need something
that's more I I don't want to say
pragmatic because people often then
associate that with what's the cash
value of the idea or you know just pure
usefulness but one of the good things
you know I'm a fan of James not a fan of
Dewey by the way because I went to
Southern Illinois and so we had so much
Dewey shoved down our throat you know
there there's the Dewey Center there and
all that the doans tend to be a little
bit triumphalis when it comes
phosh but James I really like and one of
the things that you see in James is this
emphasis well two things one one is this
emphasis on the need to be experiential
and experimental in in philosophy and
even in Psychology and then the other
thing he says that we can never get away
from our and he uses different terms
sort our passional our valal nature
there's going to be some like
commitments that we have that are not
fully understood but we should should we
should see where they go you know and so
those can inform a sense of Truth
knowing we can always get it wrong you
know we lots of things I'm sure you and
I thought were true about the world or
human beings in our 20s that now we like
wow what the hell was I thinking yeah
yeah and about ourselves right true yeah
yeah yeah um yeah no I think something
like that's right I mean
um there's no Gods I view right so yeah
right is unless we think there's a God's
eye view then we're always going to be
sort of stuck in a position of um I
think
um revisability right where revisability
is always I mean this is the quinian
pragmatism sort of stuff right is we've
got our our best available systematic
theories right that guide us as well as
they can and and we might very well
think they're true right and and they
might be right but but I think given our
sort of position as finite worldly
situated human beings with as as you
talk James's passional nature sort of
thing right yeah we have to make
commitments about which we can't be
certain and um you know given that
um I think revisability you know
thinking that it all might be revisable
is the right way I mean there's there's
this bit from Plato's kryo that I lean
on here a lot where um Plato Socrates
says to his friend kryo he says look
kryo I'm the I I am now and always have
been the kind of guy who goes with the
argument that seems best to me upon
reflection right yeah right and he
doesn't say I'm committed to the
absolute truth of everything I believe
no he says I'm going to go with the
argument seems best me upon reflection
and then he says if you have something
new please tell it to me and we'll
examine it otherwise let's just kind of
get on with it right so yeah so so I
think that's I mean I think that's the
socratic view I don't think you know I
think we can go all the way back there
for the right sort of attitude you
there's there's two other things about
that that short dialogue that I think
kind of stand out one is at the very end
he's like okay you've said your thing
and the laws have said their thing and
they're what they're saying I just keep
hearing it in my ears Maybe I'm Wrong
about this but you know I'm you haven't
succeeded in displacing them but the
other is you know something that
um I I think a lot of
people uh sort of glance over so there's
these three things that Plato three
modalities of value Plato keeps bringing
up over and over again in conjunction
with each other the uh the good and the
bad the agathon and kakon the just and
the unjust and then the beautiful and
the Ugly the Kos and the isos and he
says you know the many they don't know
any of this stuff they they jabber about
this all day long you know and we need
to listen to the person who actually
does know about these sort of things and
he doesn't say I'm that guy which is and
in other dialogues he he says quite
explicitly I'm not that guy yeah yeah
right the knows so he knows that the
crowd are full of crap yeah actually not
even full of crap they just they don't
know what they're doing they're all over
the map so to speak you know ask them
one thing one day they'll say something
different the next day that's right but
he does hold out this Prospect there's
got to be somebody who who actually
understands these things so we got to
approximate to them that's right that's
right it's I mean it's something like an
asymptotic ideal yeah maybe we can
approach yeah yeah regulative ideal
right which would mean it would also
have like a there would be a cumulative
process there's no like pill you could
take or switch you can flip or anything
that gets you right from here to to hear
so this brings us back to doing
philosophy as a way of life as a
sustained
sort of
endeavor and and so one of the things I
did want to ask about with your prison
students um now mine were I would say
you know the average age is much older
than
undergraduates some of them were as old
as like 70 um I would say the average
age is probably around 30 or so
um and you know it's a very different
sort of circumstances they have less
distractions in some way than the the
ordinary undergrad graduate so how does
the class work differently with a a
population of prison students compared
to regular
undergrads uh in a lot of different ways
but in some ways very sort of similar
right um okay uh I I've sometimes made
the
analogy with especially like with uh
when I'm dealing with in the Men's
prison okay like so so to my fellow like
College instructors something like this
imagine you've got a class of very
interested members of the same
fraternity oh yeah okay yeah right they
live together they have shared lives uh
outside of the classroom uh they can
sometimes get a little Rowdy and prod
each other maybe some of them don't
really like each other that much but
some of them are like best friends and
roomies and um uh but they're interested
and and they do they do all the work and
then some which is kind of maybe unlike
most of my experience with fraternity
guys but
um um so so they can be a little Rowdy
and a little bit uh R other yeah um but
they but they're
intense um in and and
rarely I mean I'd say their sort of
level of interest in like what I'm
teaching
them you know some of them are really
into it some of them are maybe ah this
is okay but they all do the work and um
and they come prepared with questions
and
um yeah so that so there's a variety of
differences um in that way but I've also
found
that smart students are smart students
yeah right everywhere I've been in my
career in prison at a college at a
community College y
um good students are good students right
um everywhere and uh there are smart
people everywhere I would say actually
in the cohort of men I'm
teaching right now well and that that
I'm administrating the program for 20
guys I would say one of them is probably
one of the five best students I've ever
had in my career oh wow anywhere yeah um
and yeah their average agees older I'd
probably put my group somewhere in the
30s probably on average okay um uh there
are some youngsters right in their oh
probably mid 20s by now most of the guys
who get into this program have been in
for a little while they have to sort of
prove themselves in right in in the
culture in a certain way so I would
guess there's there's probably a couple
in their mid 20s but none younger than
that and then there's uh there's
definitely a few older than me um
yeah but I put the majority of them
somewhere in their 30s and in in the
case of our program it's like
every they've committed every crime you
can imagine um I have people who
committed multiple M murder and I've had
people who have done
like you know I mean they're they're in
the state prison system so they've done
felony level stuff but right right yeah
you know property crimes all the way up
to multiple murder and everything in
between uh and so they come with a
wildly different set of Life Experiences
than most of my 18-year-old
freshmen as as you might imagine and um
yeah yeah you know and most of them come
from you know the majority of them
strong majority of them you start to
learn a little bit about their life
story and you're like how could you have
not ended up here right you know I mean
poverty intergenerational
trauma abuse substance
abuse everything you know all that stuff
and um and how could they not have ended
up there is is really what I say about
most of them you know I myself as
somebody who's struggled a lot with
anger problems since I was a kid which
got me in so much trouble I wound up
being in a juvenile detention facility
and a ward of the court for a while you
know I when i' talk with some of these
guys I I'd be like wow I could have eat
easily ended up here myself if things
had gone just a little bit differently
if if this person hadn't been around in
my life and and it was uh quite helpful
for me to quite humbling you know yeah
no I mean one of the things I've been
convinced you know having been worked
with incar working with incarcerated
persons you know for a number of years
now is the gap between most of them and
me in terms of where we ended up in life
is much smaller than you might think
yeah no I would I would agree with you
on
that generalize this the gap between us
and Us in general people in general I
think I think a lot of people on the
outside think ah there's the prisoners
they're all bad people you know yeah and
they don't realize how easy it is
especially here in the United States to
to wind up in prison and you know you
mentioned monsters so there were two
that I was going to bring up and I was
going to sort of this I don't wanted to
get into war stories kind of stuff
so there were who had done horri things
who were you thinking it through
oftentimes using the resources of
philosophy or religion and you know
engaging in some sort of ongoing moral
reformation and they would point out out
another guy and they'd be like I'm a bad
guy but that guy over there is evil and
I don't think he should ever get out
because he scares the crap out of me and
I'm a tough guy you know and seeing that
was really quite interesting the other
thing that I would be kind of curious to
get your take on and this could be like
pure anecdote like I'm I'm me and my my
friends who compared these notes were
just outliers but you know murderers um
kidnappers even even rapists are often
pretty straightforward in their
psychology and what they're like as
students the people who were child
molesters they were the ones I found who
often tended to be um the subverters of
the class so they they' they'd want to
question everything and it seemed as if
they needed the world to be wrong so
they could be right you know and I
didn't have that feeling with anybody
else and I started doing this thing
where I would I wouldn't look up
anybody's crime the first semester that
I was teaching them but if I got a that
kind of vibe from them i' look up
everybody afterwards and oh that guy
he's in there for murder okay that guy
you know uh selling drugs because you
know we have these crazy sentencing laws
for for drugs um but you know almost
every time that I had that sense about
the student turned out they they were in
there for for child molestation yeah and
I had a friend who I only taught at one
prison Indiana State Prison because I I
lived close by but he taught all over
Indiana and he taught at Miami
Correctional
Facility and Miami has two different
Wings to it and they're both medium
security and Indiana did this um this
experiment of taking all the sexual
offenders and putting them into One Wing
of Miami now Miami still had prison
education going on during that time and
he said that um he taught on both of
these sides of the prison and when he
would come home his wife could tell by
his demeanor which side of the prison he
taught on because the whatever you want
to call it like the psychic weight of
dealing with these guys over here was
very different than dealing with these
guys over here so I was wondering did
you have any experiences like that or
have you heard other people saying yeah
yeah I mean so so the cohort both in men
and women uh that that we're teaching
have people who have committed crimes
against children sexual or violent
um and not that I'm sure there's there's
not a lot of difference uh between those
um yeah and
and you know I a lot of them well and
and because I'm an administrator of the
program and I kind of run the admissions
process one of I have I have to know
what they done right right yeah right so
and and at various points of my doing
this I've also brought undergraduates in
to be discussion leaders and things like
that so in cases like that I wanted to
know what they'd done so that I could be
better informed to watch out for some of
these young students right who who might
get sucked into some sort of
manipulation or something yeah turning
as they call it yeah right so so I
wanted to be able to keep an eye out for
that um but yes there
are
um
knowing so so I've had a few experiences
where
where with most students I'm able to
sort of look past their crime and see
them as students right yeah but there
have been a couple of cases where I
couldn't really do that and there were
both the cases of people who had
committed sex crimes against young
children um and one of them was somebody
who had he was serving multiple life
sentences because he was a Serial sexual
abuser of multiple generations of his
family over over decades oh boy yeah and
and the the thing that was really a
kicker is like in our first class
meeting he started talking about how
much he loved his
family and that against the background
of knowing what what he was imprisoned
for made it really hard for me to see
past
that um there was another one
who um was clearly
ostracized from the other students in
class and I knew he had a crime like
that um but he was
also kind of uncomfortably be around and
one time after class he pulled me aside
and he wanted to tell
me uh that he didn't do it
okay and it's my respon why was that
important to him uh because you were his
instructor I think so right you know
he's like I just want you to know that I
didn't do the thing they said I did and
I knew I knew that he had had a pretty
long history of getting like beat up on
the yard yeah and stuff like that and um
and he was a pretty creepy guy I I wish
I had a better word to say that but no
that's that's that that's exactly how it
feels yeah and and I just looked at him
and said look I don't care for the
purposes of what we're doing here none
of that matters to me whether you're
guilty or innocent right but it was he
was really insistent and
um and I that was pretty uncomfortable
um most of the
guys who've I I mean I don't want to say
this too nonchalantly I guess but like
most of the guys who are in for
like violent stuff I I I kind of feel
like I get in a way right yeah yeah you
know I mean especially when you learn
about some of the
circumstances I'll also so I'll run this
past you as well so I spent a lot of
time at that one prison because that was
my full-time place and so I'd have a lot
of these guys in class after class and
then you know you're there in the
education building they're kind of
hanging around and after a while some of
them would open up to you and they'd be
like yeah you know I I tell the judge
and the you know the chaplain and the
reporters and I didn't do it but I did
it you know and I also did these things
over here and this guy over here kind of
had it coming to him this little thing I
did over here was really terrible you
know and they show some interesting
moral distinctions you know and um it
was it was it was really quite quite
interesting to to hear these these
accounts and you know with some of them
you could tell they were really trying
to like figure out how to turn the and
this is what philosophy of life is in
large part about how to turn the screwed
up being that you figure out that you
are after you strip away all the bravado
and lying to yourself about stuff and
people making excuses for you're like
wow I'm really screwed up man what can I
do you know and that and they were they
were working on that you know yeah no
yeah no teaching this flos away life
course you know so some of the students
in in this cohort of students I had had
in like one-off classes multiple times
right so so I'd already had a rapport
with some of them uh and um I've gotten
some really this sort of course in
particular especially having them do
their own versions of an apology oh yeah
yeah right is was really sort of a
chance to open him up one
one probably my favorite case of this is
there was a guy who's a multiple
murderer and
um when we were learning about Socrates
and we were talking about Socratic moral
intellectualism right that that no one
does wrong on purpose right we always do
it thinking it's the right thing and we
we were talking about he goes I just had
this huge Revelation right it's like you
know every time I go you know and he
what what happened is he murdered his
entire step family okay and um he said
you know I go I go before a parole board
or you know all these people want to
want me to talk about you know all how
remorseful I am and how I know what I
did was wrong and he says I've always
had this really hard time with that
because what I thought I was doing yeah
was protecting my father
and I don't want I I'm not sorry for
wanting to protect my father yeah I've
now come to realize that what I did was
not doing that right and so I I
I'm the idea of Socratic moral
intellectualism allowed him to sort of
articulate this tension that he had
about and he knows that committing these
murders was
wrong but he also felt like wanting to
protect his father is right right
wanting to he's right yeah being able to
articulate that make those distinctions
and tell a narrative that's no longer
simplistic I only did this I think
that's the sort of thing that parole
boards would want to see or at least I
hope they would you know well maybe not
but yeah yeah I mean some people are on
parole
boards for all sorts of different
reasons let's put it that way yeah
that's that that's quite true Indiana
didn't have them um really well they
they did for a long time and then
interestingly so the prison that I
taught at was the one where they carried
out executions as well and Indiana had a
long um Hiatus where there was a
moratorium for about 20 years on
executions and then um the legislature
changed the the status and they started
doing executions again and one of the
guys who was being executed was usually
an ex ution would take place there were
the prisoners were ambivalent about it
they'd be like well you got to
understand he was in these circumstances
and you know maybe the cops framed them
or stuff like that this was the guy who
had ruined parole for all the other
Indiana prisoners so nobody mourned him
what he' done is he he'd been um saying
if you let me out I'm gonna kill my wife
and so they they they did that they let
him out he went and killed his wife and
then you know the they argued probably
within the the Indiana legislature see
you know these these animals don't
deserve parole let's get rid of it right
so you only had good time and uh time
cuts for various things um so no
compassionate release of any sort um and
so he he had so much ill will that
everyone was you know they actually
they'd always lock the prison down
whenever they executed anybody because
the prisoners would get upset and the
prisoners were like we don't need a
lockdown for this guy yeah you know
we're all we're all with you on this one
which was quite extraordinary to to see
can we have a cheering section or
something right yeah I think if they had
had the opportunity for that they
probably would have asked for it you
know yeah but and it's interesting
because it shows
this this sort of that moral categories
are still very active within a
population where people have done things
wrong it's not like by by actions they
have indelibly stained themselves as
moral agents they I mean they may feel
that way but they're still able to carry
out some pretty sophisticated moral
reasoning yeah you know yeah and
especially if you give them some tools
to do it yeah yeah you know I mean I had
a I had a case and I'll say this because
I don't think they'll ever hear this
right but
um I had our mutual friend masimo uh
come do a guest Zoom thing in this class
okay and and they got a they got a huge
kick out of that but there was um one
particular student who sat like right
Square in the middle in the front and
and we were all on we were on zoom and
they were on Zoom One camera for their
whole room so this guy was like kind of
like right in the middle of the video
and he had to get up for some reason or
wanted to get up and he missed some of
the discussion okay and then he came
back and he asked a question that we had
just been
discussing and you know sometimes that
happens one of the guys give him a hard
time because of well so we took a break
okay took a quick break and you know
that their Zoom stayed on and all of
that and I came in and put on my headset
and I was listening and a couple of them
were pissed at this guy oh you're like
that was so disrespectful I can't
believe he would do that right and then
one of them actually wrote about it in
in their next
assignment for the class about like how
they were trying to deal with their
anger and here was a situation in which
they were got angry and and uh yeah it
was super interesting right I
mean that they still sort of engage in
um you know there's certainly moral
hierarchies even within a prison that
sometimes uh people on the outside just
think they're all a bunch of animals
right but there's clear moral
hierarchies yeah you know um
I'll say this too so Indiana got rid of
its prison education and and it was in
in large part because it was dependent
on a state grant for lowincome students
that after the pel grants went away yeah
um prison education had to be funded in
other ways and a lot of States just
folded up their programs all most did
most did yeah yeah so Indiana for a
while was kind of a leader in prison
education they had 10
different colleges and universities in
the prison
Ball State University where I was
teaching for had 130 professors teaching
in the prisons nice so it was it was
massive and then in 2008 they the
legislature decided that these grants
couldn't be used for prisoners anymore
and then it then it went away and they
brought it back with a a community
college taking over things Ivy Tech
which is and and um the Holy Cross women
were doing some things I know true but
that was all privately funded right so
yeah well yeah that that's right so so
like Grace College was pretty big in the
prisons as well and I think they
probably were able to continue or at
least teach out their their students you
know and um I think a lot of people
don't
realize that just from a like a purely
cost benefit uh point of view prison
education is a great idea because you
look at um the recidivism rates of
people coming back if they've had a ba
or even an associates degree and they
just they just plummet you know it's
well it's it's insane I don't know if
you know the latest numbers right but
reivan rates fiveyear reivan rates
approach 80% nationally right right yeah
yeah um but what the latest data is
showing that's been studied so this is
probably a couple years old but
um when uh they take as much as one
higher education course that reiv Vision
rate drops 43% wow and uh for if they
get a bachelor's degree reism rate drops
to below
7% well that tracks with there Indiana
ran one study and then buried it because
what they found is it was around 66%
Statewide this is like 2006 or so yeah
and with an Associate it dropped to 12%
and then with a bachelor it dropped to
6% yeah yeah and and you ask yourself
why what's what's going on here and it's
it's not you there's a lot of
explanations well they're better
equipped for getting jobs not really I
mean it's very hard for xcon to get jobs
anyway probably harder now I think than
it it used to be in the past um so
that's clearly not it it has to be about
what giving them as you mentioned tools
you know giving them the tools that are
provided that we kind of take for
granted in education giving them the
opportunity to to learn them and then to
use them them it it's not like a
guaranteed while you throw somebody in a
class and they turn into a wonderful
person over night no but it's a lot
about those sort of soft skills that
that yeah you know they even talk about
in Business Schools right soft skills
about like the ability to communicate to
think to learn right one of the things I
think that's most important about higher
education inside or outside of prison is
um not what you learn it's the ability
to learn how to learn right that's right
yeah you know I mean there are all sorts
of studies about you know how you know
the percentage of people who actually
end up working in their field of their
major in college is really low right and
even if they do for a while they'll
often switch out and and another thing
too is even if you come out of a
technical um you know a technical field
like like engineering or something like
that you get hired and they still have
to teach you their systems anyway right
yeah you know and so so there's there's
almost no straight from the classroom
into the into a career field um for for
any field right but what you really do
gain is all is the ability to learn how
to learn right um you know to learn how
to learn those new systems at the new
job to to Lear where to go for
information when you don't have it yeah
where to go for information where to um
you know and how to relate to others How
to Think Through how to communicate
right these are the sorts of things that
a degree
um in almost any
field will will help you get um much
better than just you know and and
there's another there's a very recent
study like a couple months old that just
came and showed out just came out that
that showed that um you know lifetime
earnings gaps between people with a
college degree and without is still
pretty massive yeah right I mean you
know look maybe some people do want to
just go to a community college or a
trade school or something like that's
what you want to do great great but the
the lifetime earnings Gap is still there
and it's still big and it can't be
attributed as it was for so long to well
they'll just hire anybody who's got a
college degree which was becoming false
even when we were going for college deg
you know but I think was true for the
Boomers you know I think that if you had
a degree back then they'll you know it
was a guaranteed entry into the door
yeah yeah so that's um where do we want
to to to steer this as as we wrap up
back to philosophy as a way of life and
what it provides students with or um
well so here's a thought I've been
playing with right and I was recently
talking to um some people about this and
I think this is one of things that ties
together everything that we've been
talking about so let me just try this
out let's let's try it on maybe and see
right is is all this stuff that we're
talking about philosophy the the
unexamined the examined life that
Socrates suggests right the the idea
about being able to use skills of
thinking and reading and writing to
examine our own lives and all of that
you know what I I've come to believe and
this again ties back to epeus in pretty
obvious ways it's really about
Freedom okay right what what what we're
talking about with all this is about
Freedom not in the sense that like um we
oftentimes talk about in you know
political contexts and stuff like
that but the kind of Freedom that epicus
was talking about I think even the kind
of Freedom that Kant talks about okay is
about that same sort of thing right it's
about a freedom that comes from
grounding our
choices appropriately right when I
choose when I I I choose because of a
certain understanding of the good and of
the way the world works and what sort of
creature I am and what sort of roles I
find myself in in society all all ideas
that the stoics talked about a lot but
but later philosophy as well right um
you know when I make my choices do I
understand what it is to be a father or
a husband or a friend or a or a teacher
uh or or a philosopher right um do I
understand how the world Works in such a
way that I can um interact with people
in ways that exhibit Justice and
fairness and kindness and all these
things that the Greeks you know were
always talking about as virtues right
yeah and and when I choose freely to do
those things I'm not being pushed around
by other people's opinions about me or I
I'm I don't get coerced
by you know um Financial exigencies
Financial exigency or like the fact that
there's a pizza over there right um or
whatever it is right I it's it's really
easy to get pushed around by people's
opinions or about why what you see
advertised on TV or uh if anybody
actually watches TV anymore um you know
um what you see on social media right
you know we see stuff these days about
you know body image problems right and
we have all these Fitness influencers
everywhere and like you know not just we
used to talk about it just terms of like
teenage girls and magazines and stuff
when when I were young but now it's it's
even worse it's men and and um all sorts
of stuff like that and when we're when
we aren't really able to sort of think
our way
through what it is to live well what it
is to live well in in society with each
other in the world we're constantly
being coerced and jerked this way and
that but when we can apply that sort of
thinking and really examine our own
lives and our own values and our own
relationships yeah with uh that's when
we're truly free because I'm not being
coerced yeah I let me bounce I I I buy
into all of that and let me bounce
another idea off of you sure um so you
know people sometimes want to say ah you
know I don't understand how the stoics
can be determinist and also believe in
Freedom and all that and I often say
well first of all you don't need to
worry about that just start doing the
exercises let's see what happens you
know H but I I kind of think of it as
you you you have freedom not in this
like big capital F you know capital W
free will kind of sense where you can do
anything you want to do that's just a a
crazy thing that traps you and other
stuff but you do have some capacity to
choose and the I I like to think of what
happens in stoicism but also in other
philosophy of way paths as you take this
amount that you've got and you you
increase it by the way that you use it
so if I can you know we'll use a
factious example you brought up pizza if
I'm eating pizza every single night
because I'm a terrible planner and I
really love pizza and I you know I don't
realize how unhealth unhealthy it is I'm
I'm freely choosing to eat the pizza but
I'm also kind of conditioned by
stuff and now somebody comes along and
they're like hey uh shouldn't be eating
pizza every night it's not good for you
I use that freedom and I'm like yeah man
I'm getting fat and out of shape and uh
I'm starting to get acid reflux from all
the all the cheese and
tomato like that and I I start
exercising that freedom now this is a
trivial example but it gives me more
capabilities it it opens up a wider
range of freedom and I don't ever want I
don't think that like even like like the
sage is this totally ethereal being
composed of Pure Freedom or something
like that right if there are sages at
all but I I it's clear that we can
increase the
the way in which we're free um over time
by by I mean sometimes it's negative you
know by practicing
stoicism and some stuff from Aristotle
and Plutarch I'd become less subject to
fits of anger
right and and when I encountered a
situation where I would lose it and I'm
still kind of pissed you know like wow
this is awesome you know I'm I'm free
and and it's just one instance of what I
think what you're talking about there
yeah I think that's right and one of the
things I keep going back to is uh I
don't know if you're familiar with
Michael freda's book a free will oh yeah
his treatment of that I think is yeah
it's a great book I think his treatment
of that is is really great in that he
says look freedom for the
Greeks is not about like Contra causal
libertarian free will yeah yeah right
but rather it's about lack of
constraint and he analoges he makes an
analogy with with political Freedom as
we see it treated in in a lot of the
early Greek stuff right and the idea is
that the sort of Freedom associated with
being say a citizen of Athens is that
you're not constrained from doing
anything
appropriate for a citizen of Athens yeah
right and then he then he says what the
sort of Freedom
that well he particularly thinks it gets
best articulated in epicus um that the
stoics are talking about is that I'm not
constrained from doing anything that's
appropriate for a creature that is
rational and social yeah yeah right um
and the problem is is if I don't really
understand what it is to be rational and
social in that stoic sense I am
constrained from acting that way right
because I have to understand it to
choose it yeah right and instead I'm
choosing I don't know to avoid pain or
to chase after pleasure or right even a
false picture of rationality like just
it to like you know exactly and then I'm
constantly I mean this is you read epic
is like well you go ahead and do that
slave right you know the way he talks
about that is that that you're
constantly a slave to your desire for
the pizza or or for your worry about the
about you know your job next year or
whatever it is right um and you know
four epic te for the stoics of course
you and I and anybody but the sage is
going to be jerked around by those some
of those things to greater or lesser
degrees but the more that we get to
freely choose what it is to be rational
and social uh that's where Freedom
lies I think that's a that that's a
great way to put it so let me thank you
for devoting so much of your time and
thought to this I'm sure this will be
very uh helpful for people and we'll put
links to a lot of the things that you're
uh mentioning discussing below you know
freda's book these uh recent studies
about recidivism we'll put stuff too
about like stoic camp and yeah great
maybe some philosophies a way of life
resources as well yeah so yeah great
great uh opportunity to kick some ideas
around and I very much enjoyed this yeah
thanks for inviting me it's been been a
really enjoyable
afternoon